bonjour à tous dans ma précédente vidéo
consacrée à passe
al je vous annonçais que j'allais
consacrer une série à ce philosophe et
compte tenu du succès de cette première
vidéo je me suis dit que j'allais battre
le fer tant qu'il était chaud et vous
proposer dès aujourd'hui une deuxième
vidéo sur pascal qui sera consacrée à un
concept extrêmement connue chez ce
philosophe à savoir le divertissement le
divertissement qui semble un sujet
extrêmement actuel extrêmement
contemporain nous sommes dans ce que de
nombreux commentateurs de l'époque ont
proposé d'appeler une société du
divertissement dans laquelle règne la
télévision le sport
et quand je dis le sport je pense
principalement au football
les loisirs les jeux notamment les jeux
vidéo et il est clair que lorsqu'on
cherche à décrire nos sociétés
occidentales modernes le mot
divertissement arrive en haut de la
liste
à tel point que pour certains le
divertissement représente même le mal
moderne par excellence le mal moderne
qui nous détourneraient de l'essentiel
qui nous détourneraient de nos
aspirations humaines profondes
nous on va voir dans cette vidéo que les
choses ne sont peut-être pas aussi
simple que cela et que ce qu'on a
coutume d'appeler le mal moderne n'est
peut-être pas si moderne que ça on
rappellera par exemple le célèbre adage
romain du pain et des jeux
du pain et des jeux une expression
parfois attribuée à tort à jules césar
qui vient en fait du poète satirique
juvénal poète romain du 1er siècle et
cette expression du pain et des jeux
servaient à qualifier la stratégie
politique de certains empereurs romains
qui consistait à apporter au peuple de
la subsistance et du divertissement
du pain et des jeux autrement dit
l'essentiel et le futile le nécessaire
et le facultatif et il est clair que
cette formule du pain et des jeux
apparaît comme la formule gagnante pour
diriger un peuple et le maintenir dans
la docilité et si cette formule est
aussi efficace
la question qui se pose c'est de savoir
est ce que le divertissement n'est pas
inscrit au plus profond de l'essence
humaine est ce que le divertissement
n'est pas un superflu nécessaire une
futilité indispensable c'est ce qu'on va
voir dans cette vidéo
alors pour introduire mon propos j'ai
décidé de partir d'une citation de
pascal qui dit tout le malheur des
hommes vient d'une seule chose qui est
de ne pas savoir demeurer en repos dans
une chambre est selon moi cette phrase
résume à la perfection le propos de
pascal sur le divertissement et le
besoin qu'a l'homme d'être diverti tout
le malheur des hommes vient du fait que
nous ne savons pas demeurer en repos
dans une chambre si on reprend cette
citation on sera d'abord attentifs à
cette notion de repos la notion de repos
qui s'opposent à la notion d'agitation
ne sont qu on a déjà rencontré lorsqu'on
a parlé du stoïcisme puisque l'agitation
dont parlent les stoïciens c'est le
trouble de l'âme
c'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler
l'inquiétude littéralement l'absence de
quiétude
l'absence de sérénité le nom repos de
l'âme
et c'est vrai que la condition humaine
est particulièrement marquée par
l'agitation l'agitation fait partie de
notre nature du seul fait que nous
habitons un monde en mouvement perpétuel
le monde dans lequel nous vivons est en
transformation permanente
il n'est jamais identique à lui-même il
n'est jamais immobile le monde de la
matière c'est le monde du changement
c'est le monde de la transformation
c'est le monde du mouvement et donc si
nous habitons un monde en mouvement il
n'y a pas de raison que notre âme
échappent à ce mouvement
il n'y a pas de raison que les corps
physique soient les seuls à être soumis
à cette loi du mouvement perpétuel
nous sommes des êtres double à la fois
corporel et spirituel
nous possédons un corps et un esprit et
s'il est vrai que le corps et l'esprit
sont en interaction permanente
on ne voit pas pourquoi le corps devrait
subir la loi du mouvement tandis que
l'âme en serait préservé notre âme n'est
jamais en repos tout simplement parce
que la vie de l'esprit ne s'arrête
jamais à savoir qu'il y a toujours
quelque chose qui vous trotte dans
l'esprit c'est très rare c'est très
exceptionnel que l'on arrive à faire le
vide complet dans notre esprit à tel
point d'ailleurs que pour certaines
personnes ne pensais à rien c'est
quelque chose de tout simplement
impossible et quand je dis impossible
c'est presque physiquement impossible
vider son esprit atteindre le vide
mentale relèverait d'une pure et simple
impossibilité physiologique et c'est
d'ailleurs d'autant plus compliqué quand
le corps est immobile quand le corps est
immobile généralement c'est l'esprit qui
se met en mouvement
l'esprit se met en mouvement dès lors
que le corps n'est plus occupé dès lors
qu'on a plus rien à faire c'est
généralement à ce moment là que nous
entamons la réflexion que nous imaginons
que nous projetons que nous envisageons
c'est à dire que nous faisons
fonctionner notre esprit
parce que quand le corps est occupé on
n'a pas forcément besoin de se projeter
par l'esprit on n'a pas forcément besoin
d'être ailleurs que là où se trouve
notre corps évidemment vous me direz
tout dépend de l'activité en question
si votre travail consiste à accomplir
des tâches répétitives
il est clair que votre esprit va avoir
envie de se balader
c'est quand nous agissons par
automatisme que nous n'avons pas besoin
de réfléchir c'est quand nous n'avons
pas besoin d'être conscient de nos
mouvements que nous pouvons nous
permettre de laisser aller notre esprit
de ce conduit larmes agir de manière
mécanique et ne pas agir servir aux
mêmes dans les deux cas l'esprit n'est
pas sollicitée dans les deux cas la
pensée n'est pas nécessaire et c'est
parce que la pensée n'est pas nécessaire
que nous pensons à autre chose c'est
quand nous n'avons pas besoin d'être
conscient de ce que nous faisons que
nous sommes conscients du reste
et cette impossibilité d'immobiliser
notre pensée ce besoin permanent de
réfléchir de se projeter d'anticiper
c'est ce que pascal appel ne pas savoir
demeurer en repos
nous ne savons pas demeurer en repos
parce que dès lors que notre corps n'est
pas occupé notre esprit a besoin de
s'occuper
alors on va bien sûr revenir sur cette
idée pourquoi nous avons besoin
d'occuper notre esprit les avances
larmes
on va déjà réfléchir à ce que signifie
ce besoin de mouvement
ce besoin de mobilité qui se traduit par
la recherche d'une occupation mental
rappelez-vous chez platon la condition
humaine est marquée par le manque
elle est marquée par le manque elle est
marquée par l'incomplétude c'est à dire
que nous sommes des êtres imparfaits un
parfait parce que nous sommes mortels et
nous avons conscience que nous sommes
mortels nous avons conscience que notre
vie n'est pas éternel et qu'un jour tout
ça va s'arrêter avoir conscience de
notre mort prochaine
c'est ce que heidegger rappelé exister
car contrairement aux autres êtres de la
nature l'homme a conscience qu'un jour
sa vie va s'arrêter et c'est selon lui
ce qui fait toute la différence
nous ne nous contentons pas de vivre
nous existons et c'est parce que nous
existons que nous sommes malheureux
notre malheur vient du fait que nous
n'arrivons pas à nous résoudre à cette
idée nous la jugeons absurde
à quoi bon vivre si de toute façon nous
allons mourir si de toute façon un jour
tout ça n'existera plus pour nous selon
heidegger cette idée de la mort cette
conscience de la mort c'est vraiment ce
qui définit la condition humaine et
c'est ce qui est à l'origine de l'
angoisse de l'homme
l' angoisse de savoir qu'un jour il
disparaîtra et c'est vrai que cette
absurde si on y réfléchit c'est absurde
de se dire que le sens même de la vie
c'est de réaliser des choses qui un jour
n'existeront plus pour nous un jour en
une fraction de seconde
nous vivrons notre propre fin du monde
il faut prendre le temps de comprendre
ce que ça veut dire
et quand je dis comprendre c'est pas
simplement comprendre
théoriquement c'est de le comprendre
physiquement
intérieurement et de se dire que oui un
jour tout ça n'existera plus c'est très
angoissant ses 13 ans
sans et c'est pour ça que nous avons
besoin de divertissement le
divertissement chez pascal ne correspond
pas simplement aux loisirs ne correspond
pas simplement à l'amusement
ce serait une vision très réductrice du
divertissement divertir étymologiquement
ça signifie détourner des tournées au
sens d'une bifurcation
quand vous êtes en voiture sur la route
et que vous empruntez une bifurcation
vous sortez de la voie principale
vous prenez une déviation et le
divertissement c'est la déviation
vis-à-vis de l'idée de notre propre mort
c'est quelque chose qui nous permet de
contourner l' angoisse de la mort et de
sortir de nous-mêmes
pendant un laps de temps pour oublier
que nous allons mourir se divertir c'est
sortir de notre voie métaphysique pour
oublier ce que nous sommes se divertir
c'est oublier ce que nous sommes nous
sommes des êtres mortels sommes des
êtres qui ne peuvent pas échapper à leur
destin
nous le savons mais nous avons besoin de
l'oublier nous avons besoin de l'oublier
parce que sens à notre existence serait
insupportable ne pouvons pas supporter
l'idée que tout ça ne mène à rien que
nous sommes sur un chemin qui ne mène
nulle part et le divertissement va être
un moyen d'oublier cette idée d'oublier
notre destin d'être mortel oublier notre
destin d'être mortel ça peut passer par
les chemins multiples ça peut être par
le loisir et d'ailleurs vous remarquerez
que lorsque nous sommes en congé on
passe pas ses congés à dormir
on passe ses congés à faire ce qui nous
procure du plaisir à voyager à sortir à
s'amuser bref à s'occuper et d'ailleurs
on voit ça presque comme une sorte de
récupération mentale
il arrive parfois que nos vacances soit
encore plus fatiguant physiquement que
notre travail mais pourtant on a
l'impression de revenir reposer parce
que c'est notre psyché qui aura récupéré
n'a besoin de décrocher
on a besoin de faire le vide on a besoin
de poser notre cerveau il n'y a là rien
de mal le besoin de poser le cerveau
c'est très humain c'est le besoin de
respirer c'est le besoin de souffler
c'est le besoin de détourner son esprit
de le divertir de ses obligations de ce
qu'il ne peut pas changer et qu'il est
obligé de supporter
faire une pause ça consiste à se
divertir
ça consiste à détourner son esprit d'une
tâche fatigante usante pour le consacrer
à une autre activité qui sera peut être
elle aussi éprouvante et usante
mais qui aura au moins le mérite de nous
faire oublier ce que nous étions en
train de faire le divertissement sert à
nous faire oublier ce qui veut dire
qu'il y a mille et une façons de se
divertir
on peut se divertir par le loisir on
peut se divertir par le jeu le jeu étant
proprement la mise en suspension du
temps lorsque l'on joue c'est bien l'un
des seuls moments où l'on ne pense pas
au temps qui s'écoule et d'ailleurs
c'est bel et bien le seul moyen que nous
avons trouvé d'arrêter le temps à savoir
de ne pas y penser
le temps ne passe que quand on y pense
et cesser de penser au temps qui passe
c'est littéralement mettre fin aux
effets du temps
la meilleure preuve c'est que l'ennui
vient du fait que nous pensons au temps
qui s'écoule précisément parce que notre
esprit n'est pas occupé par autre chose
on pense au temps qui s'écoule quand on
n'a rien d'autre à quoi pensez et cesser
de penser au temps c'est ne plus être
sous son emprise
le divertissement peut se trouver dans
le jeu il peut aussi se trouver dans le
travail parce que qu'on le veuille ou
non le travail est une occupation
c'est une occupation physique c'est une
occupation au mental le travail permet
de détourner notre esprit de l'idée de
la mort et même si on a coutume de se
plaindre de notre travail même si on a
coutume de dire que notre travail nous
épuise on peut très bien développé une
dépendance au travail
il ya des personnes qui sont
véritablement désintoxiquer du travail
les personnes pour qui ne pas travailler
c'est se laisser mourir c'est ne plus
être utile c'est ne servir à rien ne
servir à rien comme quand on meurt ce
sont
utile c'est un moyen de se divertir
parce que quand on pense à l'utilité de
ce qu'on est en train de faire on pense
pas notre mort avoir matière à penser
c'est avoir une occasion de ne pas
penser à notre mort et le repos dont
parle pascal le repos que nous sommes
incapables de supporter c'est cette
absence d'occupation de la pensée qui
alors se retrouve face à elle-même la
pensée confronté à elle-même ne peut
qu'aboutir à l'idée de la mort et donc à
l' angoisse la souffrance psychologique
liée à l' angoisse de la mort peut être
une souffrance extrêmement redoutable
bien plus redoutable que beaucoup de
souffrances physiques vivre l'angoissé
de la mort c'est vivre l'expérience de
l'auto anéantissement
c'est vivre le spectacle de sa propre
disparition
c'est très compliqué de supporter ça et
quand on est confronté à l'angoissé de
la mort toutes les recommandations
extérieur qui consiste à nous dire n'y
pense pas vit l'instant présent tout ça
ne fait aucun sens à ce moment là parce
qu'on décrète pas de penser à la mort
c'est pour ainsi dire l'idée de la mort
qui s'invite chez nous sans notre
permission
le seul moyen de la rejeter hors de chez
nous c'est de se divertir
c'est le seul moyen il n'a pas d'autre
donc le travail peut être le moyen de se
divertir
c'est à dire le moyen de détourner notre
esprit de l'idée de la mort et de l'
angoisse qu'elle génère
dans tous les cas ce qui compte pour
nous c'est de combattre l'ennui c'est
d'occuper l'esprit c'est de ne pas être
prisonnier de cette cage en forme de
roue ou toute prise de conscience rime
avec souffrance le divertissement
c'est le moyen de ne pas se poser la
question à quoi bon c'est le moyen de
remplir un vide qui pour nous est
synonyme de mort
c'est ce qui permet de conjurer le
silence remarqué comme certaines
personnes sont allergiques au silence
comme si elle avait un besoin
irrépressible de remplir le vide
d'occuper l'espace un espace qu'il faut
combler l espace qu on ne peut pas
laisser vide parce que ce vide nous
ramène au vide de notre propre
disparition
l'être humain cherche à combattre le
vide
l'être humain fui le néant et pour ça il
a besoin d'être divertis
est ce intéressant parce que parce
qu'elle disait lui-même que ce qui
définit la condition humaine
c'est à la fois sa grandeur et sa misère
pourquoi sa grandeur parce que nous
faisons partie des êtres conscients
parce que nous sommes capables de nous
représenter notre propre condition de
par ce fait nous avons un statut
privilégié parmi les êtres vivants être
capable de se questionner sur le sens
être capable de se poser la question de
notre origine et de notre destination
c'est pas rien la grandeur de l'homme
sait qu'il est capable de concevoir
l'idée d'un fini c'est qu'il est capable
de concevoir l'éternité c'est qu'il est
capable de s'auto surpasser en
permanence il est capable de
transcendance c'est ça qui fait la
grandeur de l'homme sa capacité à la
transcendance et en même temps ce qui
fait sa grandeur fait également sa
misère parce que cette capacité cette
faculté à la transcendance
c'est ce qui nous ramène à notre
condition mortelle
conscience de la mort et cette
conscience de la mort ne peut
qu'apporter le malheur on a souvent
associé pascal un philosophe du
pessimisme un philosophe obsédé par la
question de la mort sorte de
schopenhauer avant l'heure pour qui la
vie oscillé entre l'ennui et la
souffrance
c'est très réducteur c'est très
réducteur de réduire pascal à un
philosophe du pessimisme mais c'est vrai
que dans sa conception de l'homme comme
être conscient et être de transcendance
il a forcément une contrepartie qui est
la conscience de nos limites ce qui est
la conscience de notre finitude à savoir
de notre condition mortelle
et pour conjurer notre condition
mortelle nous avons besoin du
divertissement
pascal le dit lui-même dans son texte
même les hommes de pouvoir même les rois
ont besoin d'être divertis ce qui veut
dire que le pouvoir les possessions
matérielles le statut la richesse tout
sa salle mais personne à l'abri de l'
angoisse de la mort c'est une personne à
l'abri de la souffrance métaphysique
finalement et seuls qui soient à l'abri
de la souffrance métaphysique
ce sont ceux qui ne se pose pas la
question du sens heureux les simples
d'esprit receuilli ne se pose pas de
question heureux ceux qui vivent leur
vie comme des automates
même les rois ont besoin de
divertissement et d'ailleurs pour ceux
qui connaissent la série kaamelott
vous remarquerez que le roi arthur est
particulièrement marquée par cette
angoisse de la mort la série kaamelott
ne se limite pas à une série
humoristique
on peut aussi trouver nature assez fine
de la condition des hommes de pouvoir de
cette malédiction pour un roi d'être
entouré par des incompétents
mais le roi arthur un moment donné et
sujets à la dépression et son pouvoir ne
le protège pas contre cette dépression
peut-être même au contraire l'amplifient
t-il et que fait le roi arthur lorsqu il
sombre dans cette dépression il part à
la recherche de ses enfants par la
recherche de sa descendance
autrement dit il part à la recherche de
son immortalité
parce que c'est ça avoir des enfants
c'est se prolonger au delà de sa propre
vie c'est se prolonger au delà des
limites de la mortalité
je ne dis pas que avoir des enfants nous
fait nous sentir immortels mais
simplement ça répond en grande partie à
la question du sens peut-être que la
question du sens prend tout son sens
justement dès lors qu'on est plus seul à
se la poser
ou en tout cas dès lors qu'on est plus
seul dans l'équation le roi arthur part
à la recherche de sa descendance
et lorsqu'ils échouent à la trouver il
tente de se donner la mort il tente
finalement d'accélérer le cycle de
l'absurde
avoir des enfants auraient peut-être
permis au roi arthur de trouver le sens
le sens de son existence
c'était peut-être sa quête du graal
personnel la quête du sens la quête
d'une raison de vivre et ce n'était pas
un hasard si lorsqu'on a des enfants on
n'a plus vraiment le temps de se poser
la question de notre mort toutes les
personnes qui ont des enfants savent à
quel point il est difficile de
s'aménager des moments de repos
on est toujours affairé quand on a des
enfants on est toujours diverti ne pas
avoir d'enfant c'est pouvoir s'offrir le
luxe de se divertir autrement c'est
pouvoir aller en boîte de nuit et boire
jusqu'à oublier notre condition c'est là
encore la recherche de l'oubli quand on
a pas
enfant on peut se permettre de
travailler 18 heures par jour on peut se
permettre d'avoir les ambitions
professionnelles et personnelles dans
lesquels on va totalement s'oublier
quand on a des enfants
les choses sont un peu différentes on
n'a pas besoin de rechercher l'oubli on
n'a pas besoin de chercher d'autres
préoccupations on en a déjà eu ni on n'a
pas besoin de s'inventer des problèmes
parce que s'inventait des problèmes
c'est le propre de ceux qui ont le temps
de s'inventer des problèmes
les problèmes parfois nous sont
nécessaires je dirais même les problèmes
nous font du bien parce qu'ils nous
détournent de l'idée de la mort parce
qu'elle disait les hommes aiment le
bruit les hommes aiment le bruit et
c'est vrai qu'on aime le bruit quand on
est chez soi et qu'on entend un bruit
dehors qu'est ce qu'on fait on court à
la fenêtre on court à la fenêtre parce
qu'on veut savoir ce qui se passe parce
que le bruit nous intéresse il éveille
notre curiosité
on a besoin d'en savoir plus on a besoin
de donner à manger à notre esprit on va
s'intéresser aux choses qui nous
concerne pas pour le plaisir de pouvoir
en parler
pour le plaisir de trouver quelque chose
à dire et de conjurer le silence c'est
très important d'avoir quelque chose à
dire pour ne pas être confronté au
silence
quand on a des enfants les silences se
font plus rares et c'est là qu'on
s'aperçoit qu'on en a besoin parfois du
silence finalement c'est quand
l'agitation nous est imposé que l'on
cherche le plus le repos c'est quand
l'esprit n'a pas d'autre choix que
d'être préoccupé que l'on cherche à se
défaire de l'agitation mais lorsqu'on a
rien à faire lorsque l'on est face au
silence
on a besoin de faire du bruit lorsqu'on
est face au vide
on a besoin de faire on peut être
capables de défaire ce que l'on vient de
faire juste pour le plaisir d'avoir
quelque chose à faire dés faire c'est
encore faire quelque chose tout le
malheur des hommes vient d'une seule
chose qui est de ne pas savoir demeurer
en repos dans une chambre si nous étions
capable de demeurer en repos dans une
chambre nous nous rendrions compte que
la plupart des choses que nous faisons
nous les faisons pour ne pas avoir à
penser ne pas avoir à penser à notre
mort pour ne pas avoir à l'affronter
montagne disait que philosopher c'était
apprendre à mourir c'était apprendre à
accepter la mort non pas l'accepter au
sens où l'on la désire non pas
l'accepter au sens où l'on voudrait la
faire advenir au sens où on admettrait
comme une nécessité liée à notre nature
et peut-être qu'en acceptant la mort
nous deviendrions digne d'être vivant
mais en même temps peut-être accepter la
mort ce serait nous tirer une balle dans
le pied
ce serait ne plus nourrir ce moteur de
l' angoisse qui quoi qu'on en dise nous
pousse à accomplir de grandes et belles
choses à chaque fois qu'on fait quelque
chose pour se détourner de l'idée de la
mort nous créons et ancré en nous
apportons quelque chose au monde
nous lui les goûts une partie de
nous-mêmes
ou peut-être que la peur de la mort
n'est rien d'autre que la peur de vivre
et que si nous voulons conjurer cette
peur de la mort si nous voulons vivre au
delà de notre mort il serait temps de
commencer à vivre alors vivons
[Musique]